welcome back from the break aren't you
guys like those nachos yeah oh yeah well
you're not here for the [ __ ] food jus
here for me to enlighten you to edify
you to send you off into the now not so
unknown future so come along with me how
to fake like you are nice and caring no
I don't too much fun now this this is
quite an important chapter as you will
see but let's get out of brass tacks
gentlemen let's get right down to it
boys let's get right down to it men are
[ __ ] what men are [ __ ] though isn't that
what they say isn't that what makes the
couscous we do bad things don't we men
do horrible hey Gnaeus heinous terrible
things things that the no woman would
ever do no no when they don't lie the
women don't cheat women don't manipulate
us do you see what I'm getting at don't
you you see what I'm getting at see what
society does boy little boys it's what
my and we are taught to apologize I'm
sorry I'm so sorry baby I'm so sorry
what is it that what is it huh did that
we need is it there their [ __ ] there
love ya mommy will let me play soccer
and daddy he hit me so that that's who I
am but that's why I do what I to [ __ ]
[ __ ] I will not apologize for Who I
am I will not apologize for what I need
I will not apologize for what I want
okay I want you got a page 18 your blue
booklets please once you do that right
now go to page 18 and you're [ __ ]
[ __ ]
once you go your way and your white box
go 23 in your white books how to fake
like you are nice and caring person